this was the absolute perfect timing to
shift over now to our guest for the show
Senator Rand Paul who is one of the few
people in public life who tends to call
for restraint when it comes to questions
of War he's probably better known for
that than any of his Senate colleagues
uh senator Paul has a new book out on a
totally different topic that is also
very important and screwed up our world
for three years and a lot of people were
deceived over and he was probably the
leading senator probably the leading us
politician calling it out and warning
about it that would be the co cover up
this is deception the great Co cover up
by Senator Rand Paul I want to get to
coid and and what happens next with coid
in just a moment first I do want to open
up with some of these foreign policy
questions senator Paul thank you for
coming on the show good morning Michael
thanks for having me so uh Senator we
open the show today with your colleague
Lindsey Graham calling for us to bomb
Iran I think because it's a day that
ends in why uh Senator Graham decided to
call to bom Iran uh is this likely is
this advisable what happens
now you know I think you do have to ask
what happens next if you were to do
something what happens if you drop a
bomb on Tyron currently if you look at
the public of Iran the people of Iran
they're very restless towards the uh
regime Restless towards Ki and actually
many of them pro-american I think the
first bomb that drops on tyon though the
nationalism of the Iranian people those
that are upset with the Ki also become
upset with the United States as well for
for an attack lindsy Graham said on
television either this morning or
yesterday that even if there is no
direct evidence we should still bomb
them uh I think that's rash unwise and
also discounts what our constitution uh
calls for our constitution calls for
debate and it calls for the people
through their representatives to decide
War I have uh many friends whose sons
and daughters are in the military 20 22
two 25 years old and if they're going to
be marched off and they're going to put
their lives at risk for the rest of us
it's Our obligation to have a a full
throwed debate on going to war anywhere
for anyone even our best of allies we
have to have a debate and there has to
be a vote in Congress and believe it or
not people think oh congress is so
feckless we should just let the
president do this Congress will never
you know get it right but after 911 the
vote was nearly unanimous my father
who's about as anti-war as you can get
voted for the 911 authorization for
Force to go in to get those who attacked
us on 911 when we were attacked at Pearl
Harbor the vote once again nearly
unanimous but we also have to remember
that after 911 many people said Iraq did
it everybody's like Iraq did it we got
to go after Iraq and I can remember the
bombs being Unleashed on Iraq and they
had so convinced our soldiers that they
were handwriting on the bombs this is
payback for 911 and it turns out they
had nothing to do with 9911 doesn't mean
they were a great regime or Saddam
Hussein was a Nobel Peace Prize winner
but it meant they had nothing to to do
in some ways we took our eye off of the
the people who did attack us on 911 so I
think the first thing is first the first
thing is if there are Americans held
hostage and our allies Israelis have
held hostage that's the first priority
is trying to free the hostages um and I
think the second is trying to make sure
Hamas can't do this again and that
they're incapacitated and that will
require a military incapacitation but
that'll be primarily from Israel you
know they attacked Israel and Israel
will respond and as much as I don't want
war I'm also not one who will be
mouthing off saying Israel shouldn't do
anything I'm going to be saying Israel
should do what they need to do and only
they can know best but I think those who
believe and want to talk about the
political situation of Gaza or the West
Bank they lose all credibility who's
going to listen to you if you're killing
women and children if you're going to a
a concert in the desert and mowing down
unarmed people who wants to listen to
your argument so those people I think if
anything have unified people in support
of Israel for the most part and those
who aren't at this point you know the
groups at Harvard or the other Middle
Eastern countries around there that
still blame Israel on this um I think
they lose all
credibility before we get to China and
coid I want to make one last foreign
stop up at the other potential source of
the third world war which is Ukraine
you're one of the few people in
Washington who very early on has urged
caution in our role in Ukraine uh how
does the attack in Israel
uh change the war AIMS in Ukraine the
situation on the ground the threat of a
a broader global
war are we going to keep funding the war
in Ukraine is there an off-ramp is this
just going to go on
forever we have no rainy day fund we
have no Surplus we have no money to give
anyone frankly we have to borrow any
money we give to foreign
countries we essentially bought it from
China to send it elsewhere but they know
there's Rising discussion and dissension
in the Republican ranks about more and
more and more money for Ukraine so what
they're going to do and what I
understand the plan will be is this week
they will link Israel's Aid which will
be much more popular to Ukraine but then
I've also heard they're gonna put in
money for Taiwan as well so it's like
just Katie bar the door we're just going
to open the floodgates of money the same
way Democrats believe in flooding the
domestic economy with borrowed money now
we're going to flood the foreign
economies with with uh printed money and
it isn't rational or or wise and what
I've asked for each time when you do it
if you think this is in our national
interest which I frankly don't think
Ukraine is but if you think it is let's
offset it let's cut spending somewhere
else there's like 25 billion dollar
worth of uh semiconductor uh refundable
credits it's basically welfare to
billion dollar companies in our country
you know billion dollar trillion dollar
chip manufacturers are getting taxpayer
money refundable tax credit is
essentially welfare uh there's all the
new money for the IRS there's 44 billion
we could take from from the IRS there's
1.7 billion that is going to the Taliban
it's an Afghan reconstruction fund and
they say they're only sending it for
humanitarian purposes but we believe the
Taliban is getting their hands on that
money and so in one sense we'll be
saying we're fighting Hamas and radical
Islam over here while funding it on the
other side so I'm a stickler for this
even for Israel I'm supportive of Israel
I'm been supportive of the iron D but I
usually ask that it be paid for people
also have to realize the Motions running
high but Israel's not short of money
Israel is a very wealthy country they're
the most heavily militarily stocked
country in the world probably other than
the us and we give them 3.2 billion a
year on an annual basis for the last 30
years they've got plenty of money and
plenty of arms in addition last year in
December the Omnibus added an additional
billion for Iron Dome I don't think
anybody's saying they're out of weapons
and if they were I'm perfectly willing
to debate it but I would still ask that
we take it from someplace else where
we're wasting it the Govern government
is full of waste but instead of that if
you tell a Democrat this they will
respond and they will say hm we
shouldn't have to decide everybody
should get what they want we shouldn't
have to make these choices and it's like
that's what legislators are supposed to
do make a choice this is important this
has to be less important and we set
priorities but that's a real problem we
have is we don't do that we just give
everybody everything in Washington
including China and including that that
lab and Wuhan right now go to
bulletproof everyone.com use code nolles
bulletproof everyone is Premier American
Body Armor manufacturer and supplier
designed and built for everyday where
their unique armor systems offer 25%
more coverage than standard armor while
maintaining flexibility and all day
wearability bulletproof everyone's ultra
light armor system is so light and thin
you might just forget that you're
wearing it your safety and discretion is
their top concern unless someone puts
their hands on you no one will have any
clue that you are protected with
bulletproof everyone you are not a
walking billboard there are no visible
logos no flashy designs their
comfortable tailormade clothing system
goes above and beyond adding additional
security by keeping you Incognito and
under the radar work or Play Bulletproof
everyone has got the perfect armor
system to fit your everyday lifestyle
and everyday budget people are worried
about Rising tensions and Rising
violence this is a great way to protect
yourself right now our listeners can get
10% off plus a free bulletproof backpack
with the purchase of any bulletproof
clothing use code nolles at check out
Bulletproof everyone.com bulletproof
everyone.com promo code nolles I suppose
this is the subject of of your book
that's come out and early on when when
you called out fouchy and you called out
NIH and you raised these questions you
were called a conspiracy theorist and
the rest of us who were not in the US
Senate were called conspiracy theorists
and then it would seem that we all
turned out to be completely right and
there's been no accountability for it at
all and add on to that at least before
this this outbreak of war in the middle
least we saw the coid restrictions
creeping up again implausibly we hadn't
seen this in something like 2 and a half
years and then again lion gate in
Hollywood adds The Mask restrictions uh
Morris Brown College down in Atlanta
ruter University up in Jersey all New
York City saying when you're in public
wear the mask social distance like it
was deja vu all over again are we headed
back for more
coid the amazing thing in the book is
that we prove that everything that
fouchy lied about is disprovable or
proved to be a lie in his own words now
we now have emails revealed from 2020
where he's saying he knew they were
doing gain of function research in Wuhan
and he knew that the research was
dangerous and he knew that the virus
appeared to be manipulated he said the
opposite in public he called everyone a
conspiracy theorist he said it was a
fringe Theory we now have one of his
chief lieutenants this uh Christian
Anderson who uh was all in saying it
came from the lab saying it was gain of
function research three days later he
flips and says oh no it you're crazy if
you think that but in private emails
he's saying it's not a fringe Theory
it's not a conspiracy theory it's the
most likely and logical answer is that
this virus came from the lab but it's
worse than that in the book we reveal
that there was a pause on funding for
this dangerous research and that it was
evaded by one man by Anthony fouchy who
gave them permission to go around the
rules and then when they set in place a
Safety Committee that said if you're
doing dangerous gain of function if
you're mixing viruses together to make
them more infectious or more lethal that
you have to go before this committee
guess what the Wuhan research all the
tens of millions of dollars that went to
Wuhan none of it ever went before the
Safety Committee so we discovered and
looking at these emails one of the
emails is from January 30 ver 2020 and
it's at 3 in the morning so fouchy at
10:30 at night gets started and it's a
series of emails that runs through
three: in the morning you get this
harried sense you get this sense of fear
building and you get this sense that he
can't sleep the last email at 3 in the
morning is to the guy that runs the
Safety Committee that's supposed to
review this he's knowing in his mind or
someone has told him this research never
went before the committee in fact we
have the email where his assistant tells
fouchy you know what we don't know how
this could have happened because it
never went before the Safety Committee
fouchy knows he gave an end to run
around the Safety Committee so it wasn't
just the bad decision to fund gain of
function resarch in a totalitarian
country it was actually the decision
then to cover it up because he knew he
would have responsibility so they spent
months and months and a year later face
to-face in committee he's denying he's
denying to my face under oath he's
saying we didn't fund any gain of
function we have never funded any gain
of function research in Wuhan so he lied
to Congress a felony and he's gotten
away with it so far so the consequences
that fouchy has faced by my last count
are nice plushy sin ofure at Georgetown
University that that and his retirement
from NIH and his millions of dollars
from speeches and books over the years
and and other sorts of ways of making M
he also got he also got a million
dollars from a foundation a foundation
gave him a million dollars prize for
being such a great person and he took
that while being a bureaucrat but you
know what he's not even gone yet he says
he's not working for the government he
said he retired but we cannot get the
information they will not reveal but we
do know that he still has a limousine
and 24-hour surveillance uh team that is
helping him a security team and we think
he does go into his office and we do
think that he's still being paid and our
question is if he's indicted is the
federal government going to be forced to
defend him as well because he's still an
employee so there's a lot going on here
that doesn't meet the eye but we've got
nothing but resistance we send letter
after letter to HHS and to NIH is he
still on the payroll they refuse to
answer we know he's getting the limo
because we've gone around them to find
the information but but he has a a limo
every day pick him up to take him to a
probably a million-dollar job at
Georgetown so it's just insane in the
leftwing media has continue to cover up
for him is there any chance I I hate to
make you put on your prognosticator
crystal ball hat now but is there any
chance that he will be held to account
or is he just protected by the
government you know uh legally maybe not
you know I've referred him twice to the
Department of Justice Meritt Garland's
not exactly uh the most objective of of
prosecutors um really is a double
standard in our country now if you're a
republican you have to be worried about
being prosecuted but he has no fear of
being prosecuted they never will but as
far as accountability yes when this
started out in 2020 he was like a god on
Olympus and nobody touched him he was
Teflon and he was in Vogue magazine and
he was modeling and having his portrait
painted and gazing at his portrait in
his office saying I am science and if
you criticize me you're criticizing
science all this ridiculous stuff but
you know what the pendulum has swung
quite a bit he Bamboozled most of the
scientific Community but a lot of them
got mad when they found out that the
letter saying that this was a conspiracy
the theory were led by Peter daac the
guy that was funneling the money
basically the bagman taking the money to
Wuhan is the one who organized this and
did not reveal his conflict of interest
even among scientists of different
opinions there's there's typically
agreement that if you're being paid for
by a certain organization or Corporation
If you're receiving money you have to
reveal that in your Journal article like
if this is done by fizer you Jolly well
better put fizer's name in your paper to
say it was funded by fizer and this is a
real problem though because when I
challenged fouchy on the vaccine
committees I said is anybody on the
vaccine committees who's receiving
royalties from the manufacturers of of
the vaccine he wouldn't answer the
question and said he didn't have to tell
us because the law protected him from
having to reveal that that's not really
you know that comforting that it's not
happening when they won't tell us right
right uh there's a lot more in the book
uh everyone should go get it deception
the great coid cover up by the great
Senator Rand Paul senator Paul thank you
so much for coming on thanks Michael boy
what a great clip that was now hey hey
hey hey hey hey ring that Bell subscribe
to the Michael and all YouTube channel
we'll see you next time